[Music]
he is the fashion world's reigning
superpower whatever aspect of the
business that you're in in our industry
everybody looks at Ralph Lauren is the
model a dream maker who netted billions
by imagining what others wished for
every time I design clothes I am making
a movie I don't think anybody since Walt
Disney has been as successful in
persuading millions and millions of
people to buy into his fantasies
wherever you go Ralph Lauren's brands
project an aura of rarefied living
Ralph's brand stands for classic
timeless fashion the brand represents
your souvenir of this fabulous lifestyle
that you want to be a part of but his
life was not as picture-perfect my sense
was and thought it would be the last
time he walked the road it wasn't not by
a long shot we used to joke that he
always had to plan to take over the
world he's taking over the world just no
doubt about it
[Music]
Ralph Lauren is the most famous one-man
brand on the planet a brand that is
synonymous with a superior lifestyle
Ralph always knew that he wouldn't win
if he didn't take risk he's always
pushing the envelope he keeps himself
awake at night he's worried that he's
gonna fail he's obsessed
he's brilliant he's irascible he's
difficult and he can also be kind and
interesting and sweet easy he's a huge
bundle of contradictions
Lauren insists that the images he
creates communicate his story and did
not participate in the show before he
was Ralph Lauren he was Ralph Lipschitz
the youngest of four children who wore
his brothers hand-me-downs born in 1939
to Jewish immigrant working-class
parents he grew up in the Bronx New York
his father was a house painter and
amateur artist living with someone for
whom aesthetics mattered would of course
affect a child in that household Michael
Gross is the author of genuine authentic
the real life of Ralph Lauren
he went to yeshiva and he wore a
yarmulke and he wore all the other
paraphernalia of Orthodox Jews every
single day he told me that at the very
beginning when he was living in the
Bronx he would go and escape to the
movie theater and literally fall into
the fantasies of the movies of that era
which was really you know one of the
great movie-going eras the late 40s and
early 50s Warren Hill Steen is one of
Lauren's boyhood friends we all as kids
looked at the movie screens and the
actors and how good they looked I know
Ralph particularly liked Fred Astaire
and he truly did project himself into
the scenes in which men like Gary Cooper
and Cary Grant were plagued he sees the
characters that populate his dreams and
his visions and that vision that ability
to step into a fantasy world
Ralph brought to the fashion business in
one of his only two major television
interviews ever Lauren told Charlie Rose
back in 1993
about the enduring impact of those
experiences
I was very influenced by movies I was
very influenced by a world that had a
sense of dream that had a sense of
something else and what I was influenced
in these places was the good guy the the
Hopalong Cassidy not the corny guy but
the there was the man on the white horse
my sense was I had an integrity inside
me about what I believed in I I did it
honestly and but I had a point of view
are very strong Warren House team says
that when they were teenagers Lauren
asked Halston's father a tailor to make
him one of his first suits but I
remember going down to my father's place
with him and it was very difficult
you know just said my father dad do
whatever he likes he says I can't please
him I said okay then that's it even
though he was a perfectionist Loren was
a guy's guy he liked basketball best I
would say okay we're all good in 2011
when Oprah Winfrey came to interview him
on his Colorado ranch
Lauren shared his earliest ambitions did
you always want to be a Cowboys I want
to be baseball player I wouldn't be
basketball player huh I wanted to be an
actor I want to be dancer actually I
wanted to be Batman if you don't that's
a secret I'm telling you everyone
happened when he was in his late teens
he and his brother Jerry opted for a
name change as ralph said to me the
problem with the name lifshitz is it had
the words in it and he endured endless
teasing that continued through school
I'm sure into the army I believe that
Ralph suggested to me that the name
Lauren came from Lauren Bacall who you
know was a great style icon as well as a
great actress following high school
lauren worked as a salesman while taking
business classes at night he never got a
degree in 1964 after a short stint in
the Army 26 year-old Lauren married
Ricky Lowe beer a receptionist he met
his office he married the girl who would
look perfect in the convertible with her
blonde hair flowing Ricki became his
model his is backstop Ricki was always I
think in the back of his mind still
looking for his place in the world
Lauren set his sights on New York's
fashion industry he became a salesman
for Brooks Brothers and then a series of
necktie manufacturers I took him to his
first polo match in blind Brook where we
were exposed to fabulous things the
silver the leather the horses the tall
slinky blonds big hats just the high
society that we really weren't
knowledgeable of but certainly it didn't
take us a moment to appreciate it that
fabulous world transformed Laurens
vision he called me up and said he was
going to open up his own business and
what was my opinion about the name and
he said he had it down to players or
polo by Ralph polo is totally elitist
hardly anybody knows anything about it
but everybody play something so there's
no choice it's gotta be players he said
okay thanks a lot bye and then the rest
is history
it was the era of plain narrow ties when
Lauren offered up a radical design
concept colorful white eyes striking out
on his own one of his first stops
bloomingdales marvin tribe was the
former CEO and president of
Bloomingdale's shortly before he died he
spoke about the brash young designer he
showed them to the Bloomingdale tie
buyer who said I like them I'll buy them
but I don't want that Ralph Lauren label
on it I want a Bloomingdale label now
his Ralph's starting and struggling in
business about to get an order from
Bloomingdale's
he closed the sample case and said I
will not accept the order without my
[Music]
several months after ralph lauren walked
away from an offer at Bloomingdale's the
renowned store called him back
I thought the ties were terrific and if
he wanted his name on it that was fine
because I felt the ties would sell and
they did other well-known names and
men's clothing also wanted in including
Paul Stewart and Neiman Marcus within a
year lauren sold a whopping half million
dollars of ties the designer had designs
on something even bigger to expand his
brand he aimed to do so he told Charlie
Rose by envisioning clothing that
himself would want to wear what you
thought you can buy in England what you
thought Cary Grant was wearing Fred
Astaire you could not walk into a store
and buy when I came along the business
was not at all like the things that I
made you could not buy you couldn't find
it Bloomingdale's saw potential and
profit in Laurens line we worked closely
it from the ties to men's shirts to
suits
sport coat slacks the total men's
collection and then he came and said
Marvin I'd like to do a women's business
I think the most important break for
Ralph Lauren was probably getting a
boutique of his own in Bloomingdale's it
was the moment when someone outside of
Ralph's fantasy existence agreed with
him and brought him into the world of
Commerce this was the first time that
Bloomingdale's had given a designer his
own in-store boutique and the business
grew very rapidly Ralph as in everything
else knew exactly what he wanted in the
shop what he wanted on the floors what
he wanted on the walls it created really
a Ralph Lauren environment and it's all
Ralph's dream menswear designer John
Varvatos was a protege of Lauren's if
you go back into the 60s and 70s people
put things on a mannequin they never
told stories
Ralph took you into a fantasy world
wealth took you to an island he took you
to the Hamptons he took you to the west
three years after his first ties went on
sale Lauren won the Oscar of the fashion
industry the 1970 Kody Award for his
menswear line and in 1971 Lauren bought
the first of what would be many luxury
cars Pulitzer Prize architecture and
design critic Paul Goldberger has
reported on Ralph Lauren's famous car
collection I think it was a Mercedes
convertible that he couldn't quite
afford at that point he bought anyway
because he understands that very kind of
aspirational reach that he's trying to
sell to other people he reached back to
his earlier fantasy that polo match and
introduced his signature emblem the polo
player but despite strong sales the
company found itself in financial
trouble to keep it going
Lauren was forced to invest most of his
personal savings 100 thousand dollars he
also hired a new business partner retail
executive Peter Strahm who pitched in
and bought 10% of the business for
$6,000 I think he was very worried they
were delivering everything late their
distribution pattern was all wrong we
solved those problems and we got the
right stores to buy the right amount of
things to display everything properly
two years after Strom's arrival and back
on track Lauren's brand got a boost when
his men's clothes were cast in the Great
Gatsby his ability to create clothes
that look like costumes that look like
clothes that looked like costumes was
unequaled in American fashion hi hi but
I actually think that the claim that he
designed Annie Hall was more important
the Annie Hall look would inspire one of
Lauren's earliest women's collections
and the designer himself was often the
featured model in his brand's ad
campaigns commercial director Jeff
Madoff has shot many of Ralph Lauren's
fashion shows he wears this stuff so
he's become the embodiment of what he
creates like Frank Purdue with his
chickens hit no Ralph in his clothes
there was an authenticity to it
the company launched a blitz of new
collections including a wide-ranging
home collection Lauren also licensed his
name to other products trading a measure
of control for capital now flush with
cash in 1986 Ralph Lauren went all-in
spending 30 million dollars to open a
standalone flagship store housed in New
York City's historic Rhinelander mansion
my wife and I were there opening day at
2 o'clock in the afternoon and I said in
the store was packed with people I said
Ralph how are you doing he said I think
I'm doing all right
and I said Ralph you're a retailer you
can ring off the cash register now and
the manager came back and said we have
41 thousand dollars in and Ralph said is
that good and I said that's very good
then I went back to my office and the
phone rings about 5:30 and it's Ralph
Marvin we have a hundred and one
thousand dollars and how is that and I
said it was terrific this is Ralph
learning to be a retailer I think it
told his story to the world anybody who
came to New York it's like on the tour
guide of New York you know you
understand Ralph Lauren's message very
clearly when you go through there when
you walk by those windows you get it as
the business continued to grow lauren
pushed his employees harder than ever
there's a vast team of designers and
creative executives they do the
designing they do just about everything
but they bring it to Ralph and finally
it's Ralph who decides and there are
actually this amazing thing little tiny
stickers that get put up on idea boards
and they say RL likes and in that act
Ralph Lauren takes possession of those
clothes of those designs and deserves
the credit
Ralph pays more attention to detail than
anybody I've ever met in my life and
when he is designing and he's looking at
the clothes he'll look and want a lapel
ever so much more peaked or ever so much
narrower or he likes to plan that he
wants it to
in 1986 the estimated worth of the
privately held company was six hundred
million dollars and Lauren not his
models was the cover shot it would seem
that life couldn't get any better for
Lauren when he launched his next woman's
collection but behind the scenes
something very alarming was shaking up
the famed designer we were atop of the
st. Regis Hotel and the finale of the
show
Ralph came out and I saw his face
unlike I had seen it before and as I was
fighting back tears I started crying
because there was something going on I
didn't even know what it was it was just
visceral no one but those closest to him
knew that Lauren had been diagnosed with
a brain tumor it was one of those things
that you just didn't want to believe
couldn't happen to Ralph what did it
mean for the future there was all those
questions at the time
[Music]
as I was riding home in the taxi and I
heard on the news reports a designer
Ralph Lauren was being admitted for
emergency brain surgery Wow oh yeah my
god sure I worried I felt so bad for him
you know
fortunately the tumor was benign after
surgery there was a long road ahead and
new priorities oh I don't think he
worried about what would happen to the
business I think he worried about living
about his life
Lauren shared his ordeal with Charlie
Rose I remember I came home from the
hospital and I took a walk in Central
Park and I was very weak and I saw some
guys running in the park running and
sweating I said to myself I want to do
that several weeks later Lauren returned
to work I think he came back even more
aggressive than ever
but I think he was a little bit more
relaxed a little bit more laid-back and
maybe was valuing every moment a little
bit more he launched a fitness wear
collection and created a top-selling
perfume he spent millions promoting
these lines and the product universe
surrounding them James Fallon editor of
Women's Wear Daily
calls Ralph Lauren a powerhouse in the
magazine world because he's one of the
biggest advertisers out there if I
launch my fragrance and I take an ad out
in or series of ads you're going to then
do a profile of me I mean look at the
number of magazines that did put him on
the cover when he had his 40th
anniversary and that reflects the extent
to which they appreciated his financial
support in past years appreciated and
also depended on it
a 200 million dollar annual advertising
budget is an 800-pound gorilla Ralph
Lauren sits wherever he wants and if
that's the cover of your magazine
Ralph's going to be there
Laurens dominance was also evident when
Audrey Hepburn presented him with the
Council of American fashion designers
Lifetime Achievement Award
there was one of his muses
his icons audrey hepburn the woman that
he watched when he was a little kid in
the movies now handing him this statue
that for him could have been the oscar
remember the princess i got her with the
launch of Laurens upscale purple label
in 1994 the company looked great to the
untrained eye after all sales were at an
all-time high but that only told half
the story
he thought Prabhakar is a retail
business journalist like every retailer
that has big dreams it just grew too
quickly there was a lot of capital
expended in order to make that brand
where he wanted to be that combined with
a very lackluster operations in terms of
distribution created really a perfect
storm for a company that was almost on
the brink of bankruptcy lauren needed a
lifeline and founded with goldman sachs
the investment firm purchased 28% of
polo ralph lauren for 135 million
dollars that was surprising to us
because we never realized that he had
been that close to the you know back to
the wall financially and I think that's
sort of what led to the goldman sachs
investment they're very good about
identifying where the growth is and
what's going to be a company that's
going to have long term growth and
that's exactly what they saw in Ralph
Lauren and the infusion of cash meant
exponential growth with Polo Ralph
Lauren opening new stores and
overhauling older ones by 1997 Ralph
Lauren was the top-selling designer in
the world consumers spent almost 5
billion dollars a year on his products
goldman sachs saw greater potential and
pressed lauren to go public he wasn't so
sure he always had concerns at once it
was a public company he would have less
freedom of action that it was no longer
his own brand because he had
shareholders and a board to do
[Music]
despite his initial reservations Ralph
Lauren decided to take his company
public in June 1997 Liz done a retail
analyst at Macquarie Capital has been
tracking Lauren's company for years part
of the challenge with going public is
that investors want to see growth
quarter to quarter year to year in a
very consistent linear fashion and so I
think in the early days of the company's
history as a public company they sort of
struggled with that when he first went
public we would cover his annual
meetings and he would stand in front of
a shair hose when Wall Street doesn't
understand me our shares aren't just
sitting there they don't really move I
wish they would get what we do Lauren
was now working to satisfy his
shareholders the company began to sell
in more stores but sales growth slowed
and profit margins declined and 16
months after its opening day high of 33
dollars a share it fell below $17 I know
that it tormented and we talked about he
talked about it he was frustrated that
Wall Street couldn't see what was
abundantly clear to him and always had
been since 1967 that he was it but he
was the guy it drove him crazy um and he
was into that environment that came a
man named Roger Farah who was one of the
great retail executives in America Roger
Farah came over and really restructured
the unsexy parts of the business supply
chain operations one thing he also did
too was it he bought back those licenses
he brought those brands back in-house
and made sure that all those brands were
underneath the Ralph Lauren umbrella
they're going through a tremendous
growth period and I had suggested that
we put together something that really
codify the Polo brand message and we
called it Ralph Lauren philosophy it's a
brand video that Lauren commissioned the
way I do collections what inspires me is
the story or a theme that gets to me
inaudible this I don't build a
collection from the sleeve or from a
specific fabric I build it out of a
dream control to him is very important
and this is a way to present a unified
message where he didn't have to be there
but it was like he was there Lauren
continued to expand with an eye on
international sales
he opened flagship stores in Milan Tokyo
and even Moscow America is represented
in France by McDonald's and Ralph Lauren
and you know which one makes our culture
look better in Paris
I think the Ralph Lauren store has
really become a kind of symbolic
American Embassy but in the summer of
2012 the all-american designer was
attacked when news reports revealed that
the Team USA uniforms Lauren designed
were not made in the USA made in China
Asus China China I think they should
take all the uniforms put them in a big
pile and burn them the company said the
uniforms for the 2014 Winter Games would
be produced in the United States
throughout his career Ralph Lauren has
carefully cultivated his own image he
has homes on Fifth Avenue in Jamaica
Long Island and Bedford New York as well
as a 17,000 acre ranch in Colorado where
he spends time with his wife and three
grown children he also spends time and
lots of money on his pet passion cards
are fun and toys and they all offer you
a different experience to me their work
for this 2010 promotional video
announces a Paris exhibit of some of
Laurens 60 plus vintage cars he once
told me his car collection is something
he does first because he just loves cars
and responds to them and he doesn't
collect art unlike most people in his
income bracket he said you know you
can't drive a painting and he loves the
idea of being able to take any of his
cars and drive it around on a Sunday
afternoon Paul Goldberger says that
Lauren has changed some of the cars
original colors he sort of looks at
something and says this is wonderful and
exciting and beautiful but it actually
could be even better and I want to make
it even more
for 40 years ralph lauren's pursuit of
perfection has kept him firmly in charge
as CEO and chairman of the board of the
company that wears his name I think that
that you know small symbol of the polo
pony is is enduring and it's something
that customers over a long period of
time have chosen this is probably the
best long-term story in my coverage
because there are these variety of
growth opportunities that are really
driving a doubling or more of sales over
the next several years the former tie
salesman at age 72 is one of the world's
wealthiest people worth seven and a half
billion dollars I think that the last
piece of Ralph's Lipshitz that remains
in Ralph Lauren is a kernel of
insecurity and it is the fuel that runs
the engine that runs the person who
personifies the brain Ralph doesn't sit
as laurels for one minute now for one
minute I mean you can enjoy the moment
but you have to understand that you have
to keep things going and you can't be a
one-trick pony we can opponent
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]